the jurgen experience my dad eats a lot
of salmon he's big into salmon
yeah but your dad's like a hundred years
old he's doing great 91 91
yesterday yeah yeah yeah how badass is
he's born in memorial day
bad [ __ ] i know i know he you
know he almost oh my gosh this is a
crazy story i don't know if you know the
story but
he was about two seconds from being
deployed to the korean war
and he was in a plane crash
off san francisco when he was 21 years
old
wow he was he was in the army and he was
doing a
flight somewhere he had done some like a
training flight or something they said
oh you know hop on this thing
and uh he said okay cool last minute
i'll go do it
he was in a plane crash the crash landed
in san fran outside of san francisco bay
and because um he ultimately
ended up there i think one person died
him and
the pilot or co-pilot i can't remember
had to swim to shore
like at night over two miles i want to
say something crazy
and you know there's tons of sharks tons
of [ __ ] out there
san francisco and this was you know 1950
so at the time my grandmother uh
they had told him that they told my
grandmother that he had gone down in a
plane crash
i thought he thought they she thought he
was dead
and there was no cell phones there was
no social media there was no anything
it took a week for him by the time he
got back and
got back to the thing to be able to call
her
after i don't get made to go to the
hospital i can't remember um
for him to be able to call his his
mother and say hey
i'm alive wow and that
is what kept him from going to the
korean war because he was supposed to be
deployed but because he was in his plane
crash
he had to stay and testify and do the
whole do this whole thing and that
they had just deployed without him wow
isn't that crazy how
one moment in time can change the whole
course of someone's life
yeah and a moment that's completely out
of your control there's there's these
weird
like sort of pathways that you come to
in life
gateways and you go left and you're okay
you go right
and the trip ends the trip's over yeah
my dad was born in 1930. that's great
before the
before world war ii that's crazy which
is nuts
what is it like talking to him first of
all what is it like
being clint eastwood's son and also
being a movie star yourself
that's gotta be weird
it's well look i'm i'm stumbling through
it just like anyone else in life you
know you're just you're trying you
taking the information you have trying
to make the best decisions at the time
speaking to my dad
it's like there's a wealth of knowledge
and fork
knocks and you're trying to just like
pull
little slivers out when you speak to him
because you he'll just say things
casually like
yeah and everyone shuts the [ __ ] up like
a dinner you know
you know finally you'll know he's about
to say something and then he'll say
yeah well that was you know back in the
60s i was with uh
frank sinatra at that place at the time
and oh yeah we did we met her and the
thing
and you go wait what did you just say
you were with frank sinatra
like wait hold on let's stop stop like
more and more give us more and then
he'll
he'll be on to something else and you
know you can't get it out of him but
it's like
it's he's just lived this incredible
life incredible
incredible so it's i you know i'm trying
to right now
i'm trying to just soak up every piece
of
knowledge i can from him listen to him
sit with him as much as possible so i
know he's not gonna be around forever
and and that's
that's terrifying you know to think
about but it's um
it's like oh man this is i gotta like
spend every moment i can does he
exercise
yeah he's super active um
obviously he's 91 so how old do you
35 so he had you way
late in life but he had three kids after
me whoa
what's the youngest the youngest is 220.
[Laughter]
20. he has had some younger younger
wives he has a 20 year old kid
yeah 23. holy [ __ ] yeah
shooting live rounds deep deep deep into
the 60s machine gun rounds
wow that's crazy yeah that was that
newscaster lady right
was that her it was it was yeah yeah
she's
she's great actually she was great but
yeah yeah yeah
you know he had a few few younger ladies
around he's such a throwback
yeah he really is you know and what's
interesting though is like
what people think about him they think
they
see this bigger than life character
but he's so much more complex
than what you see and the movies he's in
he's
there's a lot of nuance it's like humans
you know it's like i'm sure all humans
people would think about you just
because of whatever and they're like oh
well he's just this thing
they don't know about your personal life
they don't know about how you are with
your kids
how you are you know how you think you
know esoterically about
things and you know when you're speaking
to your wife like
he's like much different than just that
he's got a lot of shades and he's
he's very i think middle of the road a
lot of things he
looks at issues and says well this is
that and it's that and
maybe there's a middle ground and i
don't know you know well there's always
this
this urge to dismiss people any any
person
you have this reductionist perspective
of who that person is
and it's hard to just go to just
be curious and it's just to say huh
like abandon all your preconceived
notions
and go uh imagine imagine being that guy
like imagine being clint eastwood yeah
imagine being lived a lot of lives lived
like a lot of lives lived a lot of lives
did you ever talk to him about what it
was like to be the mayor of carmel
he was the mayor when i was uh when i
was a young kid i was
uh you know a few years old
um i think he had his fill of politics
that was it
because they asked him they they were
kind of like well you know you've been
the mayor now
why don't you you know go for governor
you know and he's like nah
this [ __ ] ain't for me let's just give
it a shot yeah it was you know i think
it was good it was
he did what he did but you know you can
never please everybody everyone's
there's always someone pissed off
there's always some conflicting point of
view
always ever talk to him about that time
that he uh pretended obama was sitting
next to him
that was bizarre it was it's like
impromptu
you know like he just like was winging
it he's wigging it yeah yeah he's doing
a bit
crazy thing to do well tv live i mean
you do the same thing more or less like
yeah but i do it in comedy clubs
but what's the difference right it's
like you go out you practice material
you're working material out right it's
like
you know there's you're getting up in
front of people doing something
it's it's it's like we call it different
because it's like oh
that was that thing but but i guarantee
you obama would not have said the things
that he thought
obama would have said obama would have
probably had some pretty nuanced
perspectives himself
sure you know like again same sort of
thing that people wanted to do to him
or want to do to other folks like he was
kind of doing it to obama
look maybe he didn't work out his
material
you know no i'm sure he didn't but it
was it was a bold choice i was like wow
how badass is clint eastwood and richard
pryor did that too
if you go back and listen to richard
pryor's old cassettes there's like
there's some of them that are available
from the red fox comedy club and you
could find them online
but i bought them from a gas station one
day in like the the 90s
these cassette tapes and they were all
like him at red fox's comedy club
and it was just him like you could hear
drinks clinking
you could hear things in the background
and ice and [ __ ] and you could hear
people talking and it was just like this
small crowd where he was just [ __ ]
around
and that's where a lot of like his most
brilliant bits came from
interesting so it's similar to what your
dad was doing but different
[Laughter]
hey look i don't i don't pretend to
speak for him
that's you know listening he can do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants he's clint
eastwood
you know and you know what one of the
things i love your dad did unforgiven
because like he went back and made
like this i mean he did obviously he did
all those great spaghetti westerns all
those amazing
and they call them spaghetti westerners
for people who don't know because they
did them in italy they just
yeah and so he did all these american
western films but they were all done in
italy and
they were all like people didn't think
those are going to be like real
successful at the time right
yeah he he was coming off a show called
rawhide
if you remember that yeah
and he was actually sick of doing
westerns at the time because he was
like been known for seven years and he
got an offer
to do this spaghetti western it was like
in italy he was like i don't know
you know what should i do the guy i want
to go to italy
never been there okay pretty good he
goes out there and he works with sergio
leone
and crazy story he comes back
actually i think he might have done all
three or he came back and did
one and he came back
and people started talking about this
movie but it was
the movie he had done he'd known was an
italian so it was like
you know and so he was like
people were saying you know this is
great movie out you know
fistful of dollars whatever it was and
uh
he's like oh that's cool i want to go
check it out no
no no no no no he didn't even know he
didn't know he didn't know it was his
movie
that was catching fire in america
and so he's like oh i gotta check this
movie he realizes it's his movie
that it caught fire and it was overnight
sensation
um and then yeah he just
kind of just i don't know fell into
doing those movies did a few of them
um and then he did his own then he
started directing and doing his own
westerns
but bringing it back to unforgiven
what's really i think most interesting
about that film is that it
is it's an amalgamation or
it's it's the whole history of his
westerns but
but really looking back as what would be
like to be an older man
and having regret having things he did
wrong
you know looking back and so it's kind
of using the history that he had created
and talking about you know what it's
like to look back at life
and you know one last ride to do things
different
for his family so there's like a lot
going into that movie
you know what i mean yeah well it was a
uh a much more sober and realistic
depiction of like uh a
killer in the west yeah you know
william money being paid yeah you know
probably not
that much money but like hey like we
need this person
dead yeah and you're the man to go do it
and it's like
also the there was a much more realistic
depiction of the way
some people react to the idea they're
about to be killed
yeah or that they're gonna have to kill
someone they're gonna be in a gun fight
where they might
they might die that's a [ __ ] great
movie man it was almost like uh
he wanted in my my the way i felt to me
is like he had all these amazing
westerns that he did but then there was
this one is like yeah you know what let
me do a real one
like let me go back and make this
[ __ ] thing
where it he sat on that script for 10
almost 10 years
wow before i made it yeah he was like
this is amazing i don't think i'm old
enough yet
oh wisdom
wow yeah wow you know what else i love
high plains drifter
yep i watched that one every couple of
years that's a good one that's a [ __ ]
great one
i like outlawed josie whales oh my god
yeah
[ __ ] loved that loved that movie
that's a great one
yeah that's a great one but there's
something about high plains drifter
that's like a ghost movie you don't
realize it it is
you don't realize there's a supernatural
element to it
yeah what is happening here yeah yeah
yeah about that one [ __ ] it's one of my
favorites
yeah your dad made some goddamn classics
and then he also made some comedies
you know every which way but loose i
mean it's what a crazy career
that's one i think they should remake
haha with who
how about you maybe would you do it that
would be weird why not could you imagine
though
you know yeah big old orangutan i don't
want to [ __ ] around with orangutans bro
you just piss it off for the wrong
reason it rips your hand stuffs it up
your ass
they're dangerous they're so dangerous
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience
on spotify you can listen to the jre in
the background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience